songs of resistance and Hope Sound in a
neighborhood where Terror and violence
once reigned
the Colombia Sport City of Buena Ventura
is celebrating more than two months
without homicides after the town's two
largest gangs the Shottas and the
aspartanos announced the ceasefire in
preparations for talks with the
government
18 year old Community organizer and
singer Alejo alumia recently returned to
his neighborhood after fleeing with his
family he was targeted for his
leadership and feared he could be
forcibly recruited in one of the warring
armed gangs as they scrambled to expand
their territory
everybody was worried living in fear
nobody could leave the house or cross
into another neighborhood
long marred by poverty and neglect when
Aventuras lived through escalating Turf
Warfare between gangs in what is one of
the main drug trafficking routes to the
United States
now locals are repainting houses and
sidewalks Commerce is picking up and
people are feeling confident again
just a few months ago this would be
totally empty not even dogs wandered
around but now with this peace building
process moving forward people are out
and about again
when Gustavo Peter took power in August
he vowed to negotiate with all armed
groups in the country as part of his
total peace policy and he sees Buena
Ventura as a blueprint for peace across
Colombia the government is hoping the
truths will lead to gangs being
disbanded in return for judicial
leniency and social investment
you're wondering for how long can the
truths last given that at least another
forearm groups operate in Buena
Ventura's rural area where violence has
increased in recent months
some gang members have been recruited as
peace operators one of them tells us
only major social Investments can make
the truth sustainable in the long term
we need opportunities we need to work we
need to study you understand
opportunities that can help us change
our expectations
who helped negotiate the truth believes
there's a real chance for long-lasting
peace
it's a different approach the government
is listening to The Gangs before there
was only arms confrontation and Armed
Forces they see an opportunity and are
betting on it it remains a high risk
strategy but for now the people of Buena
Ventura are celebrating peace hoping
that this time their expectations will
be fulfilled Alessandra Al Jazeera
Buenaventura